now what yeah what do we got okay
mmm Sicilian um Sicilian what let's go
with this still learning about this open
or not hmm
okay well this could very easily
transpose into a French hmm
or even like pan off boffin ik depending
on how I would recapture now I wonder if
I could be doing pawn push here thinking
just the lat the turn when I was just
playing in I ended up flying this but I
don't know if it's great so French
is that where we're gonna be having I'm
gonna try this
getting ready for a Bishop to b5 of d4
Bishop d7 to b5 here we go d7 to b5
so now
trying to get rid of the bad guy my
light-square bishop is my bad bishop
what are the options here for my
opponent
so now what my opponents invest in quite
a bit of time here so maybe just an
unfamiliar territory or what what is a
possibility right there I think c4 is a
possibility
I'm going to take just to make sure
there's no sea floor stuff so now piling
up here hit three times another defender
there is Bishop here the Queen is
guarding b2 now laterally and what next
what should white do okay I guess you're
gonna be seeing before and I'm not
really sure where my bishop should be
retreating so if I go to e7 where does
my knight go
bishop here
um I'm gonna go there and maybe just
give up my maybe just be okay with this
type of structure doubled doubled H puns
my opponent would be giving up their
dark square Bishop then not sure f6 is
something I'm kind of shying away from
because of a 6b okay now I actually have
a time to play here since the bishop is
the bishops view is blocked and now just
in the nick of time get my knight here
okay so now I have some pretty good
coordination between my pieces my knight
can be kicked away any second with b5
and I think I just play here I don't
think there's a better Square than that
this is my only recapture is my Bishop
close to being trapped is it G v h6
queen h5 and it be trapped but I mean if
g5 I think I play Knight d7 to get my
other night to this square I think that
would be the correct treatment so right
here I believe is best maintaining
pressure on my opponents side and now I
am a bit more concerned about my bishop
being trapped where am I no I'm not
or maybe I am g5 threatens Queen here
sabji 597 Knight d4 stopping my knight
from even getting here that's enough
that's enough to scare me back to east 7
h5 is a possibility maybe if the Queen
leaves I don't know if I do better to
cap I don't do better to Kassar
here I like retaining this option to
play h5 and now with that move I start
to cringe because I don't know should I
be doing this move I'd like to get my
Knight to f5 this my opponent has good
good squares for their minor pieces huh
the rook is opposite my queen I really
don't like that not at all I don't want
to Castle queenside maybe this is met
with just push and then take on this
square or maybe just take right away on
this twice how do you defend I'm gonna
go with this one taking away these this
square the c5 is my knight gonna be
pushed away
actually if pawn push uh-oh
my knight can't go to a5 any more Knight
takes pawn takes Bishop takes that's
that's a healthy pawn that that's just
taken there so guess what my dad has to
run home go home Knight now what
okay
now I'm gonna do this h3 okay I have a
file now against the king let's do that
right now and then get to this square
I'm if this pond gets pushed I'm gonna
play here if takes takes Queen f7 my
king would have this square available in
fact I'm gonna go here right now getting
ready to just play King here to connect
my rooks King d7 I want to have that
square available and it should be in
okay home in fact I'm also getting ready
for just a night here you might have a
bunch of exchanges going on on this
square so who's King is safer really not
sure it's a tough call right there
Knight here looks pretty good followed
by Queen here I'm hitting the Queen
that's the other nice thing about that
okay
Queen here is threatening upon it's more
active let's go it's more active I have
a new square for my King to run with so
I have a lot of pressure now this rook
is or this file is uncontested so what
do you do what does one do here where is
the knockout is there even a knockout
could it be as simple as double up rooks
and then get to h2 is there way to chase
the Queen away so I could get to e2 I
could chase the rook away I don't know
what that really does though that allows
Queen here with Czech eventually
gonna go with this I think I have the
safer King and now my opponents in
trouble because now my bishop comes to
life h2 is is gonna be mine and this is
a winning material now may very well be
mate I'm on the night twice
alright is there anything better just
cash in its cash in and move quick get
on this looking for mate on g2 made on
g2 coming up this is check this is check
this is mate
one two there we go all right good game
let me back up let me back up that was a
tight game very very tight game Wow okay
so not so much a Sicilian landed you
know it starts out Sicilian but with c3
we're entering a different setup we're
entering French defense so I went with
Queen b6 cuz I don't want to bring my
knight here coz of that idea I want to
get my light square Bishop out and again
I think this is something to be
considering I'm pretty sure it was at
this point my opponent had a little bit
of a think I think c4 after a couple
takes or just one take something like d5
an ensuing d5 move to not allow me in
other words to exchange in my c4 the
deep on that could be quite disruptive
to the black structure and result in a
4-3 majority in favor of white on the
Kings side so and this is another one I
wonder if white should allow me to pivot
on h6 and then f5 maybe they could be a
bit more annoying to me and how about oh
how about this how about how about
here Bishop III hit my queen maybe they
were they were worried about Queen c7
then I'm on this twice I mean maybe just
Bishop f4 and then Knight pivoting about
to this bead three squares and
improvement but I'm able to get to h6
not worry about having to deal with
double H pawns maybe and I think maybe
maybe actually g5 all will end up
netting this Bishop g5 I was thinking
Nighy seven to f5 but I think my
opponent would have something against
that g5 97 Queen g5 Knight f5 and then
Knight to d4 something like that
removing a defender for my bishop and if
g5 h r FG v h6 I think just queen h5 and
then there's this pin against my rook my
bishop will end up getting captured so
that was uh that was something maybe my
opponent had right there and then it got
really uh really tight here my opponent
does have to be a bit cautious because
if they if they're not making the right
kind of moves that could turn out where
I could access their King maybe keep
maybe keeping the Queen on this diagonal
is important just to just to negate this
idea of h5 and this rook coming to life
I don't know how I really make much
progress so in other words I don't know
if Queen here is a correct idea maybe
maybe white could be going with Brooks
rook C to double the rooks and then upon
push maybe first inserting a three or
something just to watch over b4 but in
the meantime the reason why I'm thinking
why can maybe be running with this is
because what do I do in the meantime I
really don't want to go forward with
castle because then forget about this
being a possibility its h5 move so maybe
a slow slow plan here by white of
doubling the rooks with the new and a3
c4 could be good but now the tables I
think start to turn I get on good
squares with my minor pieces and I am
coordinated even though my King looks a
little bit vulnerable I'm not so sure
it's any more vulnerable than the White
King especially with my knight being
able to rely upon this efore square this
hole on the white side of the board so
okay and yeah it starts to be trouble
all right good game Airwalker beginning
let me close out